hey guys what's up this is andrew for
consensus.com
so in this video i want to make a big
update guys on all the crypto markets
because we had a bloody week we saw some
very very strong
moves down on all the crypto currencies
and i am still bullish i'm still bullish
for the long term
and i'm gonna explain in this video why
let's get into it
[Music]
in this video i'm gonna start with the
bitcoin because
you know even if the king is to be
beheaded it is
still the king today and when the market
is going down
it is the one that is gonna lead the
other currencies so
i think it's the most important
cryptocurrency to understand
and from this analysis we can then
better analyze the other currencies so
let's start
here in my last video but you can
basically check all my videos guys for
the past
three months i was bullish the whole way
up and i turned bearish guys here all
right when we broke
this one two three four five in yellow
here this one
when we broke this ending diagonal that
was the fifth wave
of my impulse in orange here
that was a beautiful one two three four
five then i
turned strongly bearish i told you guys
you know for the past
three weeks roughly i'm saying that
bitcoin is gonna correct and i was
expecting this one two three four five
to happen here
then in terms of levels i told you that
we would probably go to 42
and that we would bounce back we broke
42
and i can show you that it's pretty
interesting to see that
you know i had some discussions with
some friends that were telling me no 43
is the support and
i was like no it's 42 000 that is
support
and you can see here that i was right
because this is my 42 000
support and why
42 000 because it's the maximum level i
had here on the third wave all right you
can see
this trend line here guys it's touching
perfectly
the top of my third wave in orange here
and
four months later guys four months
later look how the market reacted
to this level this was sunday i had some
friends
a lot texting me hey bro what should i
do
what do you think of the crypto market
and i said man it's been three weeks i'm
bearish
three weeks i'm telling you and right
now
we are actually bouncing from the 42 000
level
here so this was on this sunday
once twice three time and then we broke
it and
here i was like alright guys we broke 42
000
i was expecting like you know a strong
move down at this time
and i said that we would probably go to
the next
support level so once again guys
you know it's always the same thing if
it's not the top of the third
then it would be the bottom of the force
so we went there the bottom of the force
guys and here we had
some strong buyers arriving stepping in
and
pushing this market higher back to the
42 000
where it got rejected again and right
now we're hovering
between those two levels in this area
so it happened almost exactly like i
said
but we went actually deeper than i
thought
now what is my view let me tell you this
so we take a step back guys
all right we take a step back it's very
important to
you know not zoom in too much to
try to get the bigger picture and we're
gonna
day time frame and guys what do we have
here
does it look bearish to you you know if
you look at this
so i i'm not even taking into account
what happened here but if you just look
at this
so forget about this one maybe first
but here guys we having one we had it
second one so this is march 20 when we
started
this strong rally so this is one wave
one two three we completed
the third wave we are correcting this is
normal usually third wave is correct to
the top of the third
or the bottom of the force we went to
the bottom of the force
that's it we are very far from the top
of the first which is at 12 000
where this would actually change
everything for now
this looks to me still very bullish on
the longer term of course
and like i'm saying for the past month
i'm here expecting guys some type of
flat
so we had here a deep zigzag so it might
be my first wave
maybe it's it's gonna be like this
that's possible here the correction
lasts
from august to september so two months
right now we're having 11th of april we
haven't
already one month and a half so it might
be the end of the correction guys and
we could also this is another scenario
had have
something like this it can work as well
because
you know there is a bit of fear right
now in this market and for the fear to
be gone
we need to have some time you know this
is usually the process that needs
to happen before the price action can
start to be really bullish again
so to me we need more time all right we
need a bit more time
so i think we're gonna stay in this area
a bit longer
and we're gonna have this strong move up
all right coming
and going around the hundred thousand
area
and from a scenario to be invalidated
we need not not only to break
uh the 30 level we would need to go much
much lower but
seriously if we break the 30 level it
doesn't look good
but still this scenario could still be
possible so we need to pay attention to
what happened
around the 30 level and we also need to
keep an eye on what is happening here
guys
this c wave needs to be complete as i
said in my previous video i was
expecting five waves here
so one two
three four five all right something like
this
but i'm not sure the c wave is actually
complete so for the c wave to be
complete guys you go back to trend lines
all right
you go back to trend lines and just
connect it's basic
very simple you do like this we need to
break this level you can see that this
was where we got rejected here guys
uh do some day trading on bitcoin you
could have this level b4
even i told you so here you connect the
high here the height that is here
the high that is here and you would have
this one this one and this one all right
three times uh rejected here we probably
gonna consolidate
i expect something like this guys
that and suddenly break out retest and
go higher all right
this is where you want to step in the
game you don't want to buy too early
because if you break 30 if you buy here
guys and you go to 28 what are you doing
you're gonna step your position
no i think you're gonna keep it and
you're gonna feel bad it can be bloody
guys and cryptocurrencies it can be
bloody so don't
buy the price action when it's funny we
have a saying in finance
we don't try to catch a fully knife
right because it's dangerous
it can hurt so here
wait for this bullishness to come back
wait for uh the price action to show you
good
signs and then it would confirm that
this abc
is done and that we are entering the
fifth wave and that the scenario that
i'm telling you guys for a couple of
months
is actually confirmed and
then guys you have some amazing profits
awaiting if this is correct because it's
a very nice level
if you enter 35 we are talking about 300
percent
so don't try to buy you know at low
levels
when the price action looks that ugly
you buy
when the price action shows you good
signs
that's how i do this quickly let's check
the ethereum
guys same story only the third wave
looked much better
here we corrected only to the two so top
of the third wave
as you can see here guys so it's more
bullish than the bitcoin
it looks better to me 2000 is a very
nice level to buy
we could go to 1400 i wouldn't be
bearish all right i would still be
bullish on the long term
so we we have two nice levels to buy the
ethereum here and we're having the 200
moving average that is coming here as
well so different scenarios
we could have an abc like this all right
and go to the 1400
we could have an abc like this flat
correction
and then revisit this level we could
also have already completed our abc
so same thing guys you go on hourly
timeframe
and you try to spot when the wave is
complete
for now this is bearish guys i would
never enter a trade like this this is
suicide
it is just too bearish all right you
need to wait you can buy here put the
stop let's just below that is a smart
trade buy 2 000 stop loss
you know by even careful guys
cryptocurrencies they make a lot of
excesses
but i prefer to buy here get stop lost
here and maybe have another opportunity
than buying here and getting stuck in a
trade that is losing
more and more every day even if the stop
loss sometimes goes against you
sometimes it's going to save your life
so here i would be buying a 2 000 stop
loss at 1
900 something like this and if i need to
make this trade three times before it's
the right one i would do it and same
thing guys
i'm expecting then one more move up to
come
at least maybe a few but like i'm gonna
make some longer term analysis later
right now guys we're focused on the
short term
if you want to see like you know on the
bitcoin actually my target this is only
a third wave as well yes one two three
four and five all right so i have a
target very very high on the bitcoin
so this is actually to me a nice buying
opportunity all right guys and let's
finish with the dutch coin so basically
it's going to follow the other uh
cryptocurrencies
so what are we having we are actually
having to me i was first telling you
that we're gonna have
a maximum level of around 0.8 actually
we went to 0.74
so i wasn't that far and i was expecting
the last move up to come
in this third wave that got actually
truncated
which means that the fifth wave of the
third wave d don't happen guys all right
i was expecting here a fifth wave and it
didn't happen
all the cryptocurrency markets corrected
together
so right now uh i think that the dutch
coin
is still bullish but i would be very
careful guys it's basically gonna follow
the other cryptocurrencies
so watch out in this kind of environment
where
everything is corrected it's not a one
currency
drop you know it's the whole
cryptocurrency market
that is actually in danger here
so i would keep an eye on the bitcoin
and the ethereum
to feel safer on the dutch coin but if
i only need to check the dodge can by
itself having a one
two three and this is maybe a four
and i think we're gonna have a fifth
wave as well but much later
this third wave is now complete and it
didn't go to the
one to twenty or one thirty level like i
was expecting
it corrected before so right now this
third wave is
finished and we need to wait for the
end of the force wave before getting
bullish again
so same thing as on the other
cryptocurrencies guys
in this kind of situation i don't like
to buy
when it's dropping i don't like to buy
the deep all right it's very hard
to know the levels you see all you buy
with the stop loss
here once again we can use the same
thing so usually we correct to the top
of the third
so this is 40 right or the bottom of the
force
so for now we didn't even go to the
bottom of the force
that is around the
0.15 level so 0.15 i would be a buyer
all right here definitely i would be a
buyer
all right if the market goes here i
would be a buyer open 15
we had here inside the force wave some
um
consolidation that actually supported
the price at 0.2
but to me this doesn't look complete yet
uh so either i would buy at 0.15
or i would wait for some bullish signals
to come so for example the typical
bullish signals
would be that we break this trend line
all right
so we have time so if we go above the
open 45 level
i would turn bullish again on the short
term for now this is bearish
careful and 0.15 would be for example
the level i would buy
or i would buy when the price action
starts to moves up again
so guys that's it for me i hope this
would help you to
make your own analysis and to understand
how this crypto market
might develop later so if you enjoyed
this video please don't forget to click
on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore see you guys